[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découverte alors allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune du Tampon plus
précisément à l'aide d'accueil de Python
sec et voici un petit panneau là nous
nous on va aller jusqu'au net nous nana
une autre temps mais avant d'aller de
bœuf nous on va aller jusqu'au fameux
troublant allez allons-nous ah ben
magnifique
bonjour bonjour Alors mettez-moi comme
ça là on est parti hier de Jacques Payet
par python lardé Fox jusqu'au gîte du
volcan et puis ce matin on est reparti
donc du gîte et puis on a pris le
rapport ça t'intéresse
Ozou et puis netbeu et puis voilà on
sort python sec bourguera d'accord et je
vois vous êtes en groupe vous êtes quoi
c'est une association c'est comme ça pas
de randonnée de Saint-Denis ah oui de
Saint-Denis
et puis on prend on accepte les hommes
accessoires ce soir le message est lancé
alors comme il est curieux c'est que
notre prochain randonnée alors la
prochaine randonnée ça sera le pat de
sable le mort le longevin Grand Coude
rien que ça même moins dépenses allagilo
retrouve mon moment rien que la même
moquette des danses
ni un soleil à cross fait pipi comme si
la nature déconnait à la paradis pour
nous rester
alors là nous ça arrive sur le fameux
point de vue où ça ne va gagner
les magnifiques alors les troubles c'est
le gardien
encore alors on a fait attention hein
encore et Nana n juste là alors il faut
savoir bonne troublant là c'est bon ça a
été créé alors lors de l'éruption il la
rencontre la nappe phréatique c'est à ce
moment que la craie c'est fameux
troublant on appelle ça aussi des mares
en tout cas allez vraiment
magnifique et bien nous sommes ça a fait
nous ça a continué notre chemin jusqu'à
le nœud de bœuf
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène
parle pas nous aller nous verrez que la
même un peu de respect pour mon pays
vraiment d'après depuis son lit au bout
de la terre non pas dit faut comprendre
pour un démon de mon pays alors du coup
au bout d'une heure 10 de marche nous
arrive ici alors nous les sous le nez de
bœuf à 2060 mètres d'altitude nous ça
nous va à fait nous va aller sur le net
de bœuf parce que le même petit chemin
par là allez nez de bœuf noir arrive
un peu le temps pour faire des repérages
et là on est là
justement pour en prendre en photo là
ben de choses pour voir parce que là on
voit d'un côté beau murale plein d'écart
ou de l'autre la planète du volcan la
pente carrossa tout ça d'accord et en
même temps de cela elle est un petit peu
nuageux mais bon quand même bien la
rivière des remparts voilà
ça c'est l'arrivée des remparts on
devine la partie haute d'abord à côté du
cratère OK dans les nuages là-bas dans
les nuages là-bas et en fin de compte
bah ça ça va courir jusqu'à jusqu'à la
mer jusqu'à Saint-Joseph oui il y a un
village comme un illette en fin de
compte dans le fond sous les nuages
là-bas qui s'appelle Roche Plate
d'accord
le paysage à côté les doux et d'un côté
là d'un coup les fracturé donc
très brutaux et tout donc pour discuter
un petit peu de à la fois du volcanisme
la formation de l'île euh la végétation
la biodiversité aussi puis le climat ici
on est à Carrefour de tout ça en fin de
compte c'est hyper riche et intéressant
côté moi en tout cas merci
du plateau du nez de bœuf si nous
regardez bien il est pas là et ben
allons-nous
sentiers piéton et en même temps VTT ah
d'accord parce que on est dans la
station VTT et en même temps équestre et
en même temps sur un sentier PMR pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite et en
même temps un air d'accueil pour les
familles tout ça les mélanger et c'est
un petit peu ça finalement l'action du
département c'est concilier tous les
usages qui sont multiples voilà pour
faire en sorte que que tout se passe
bien que chacun profite de
tout ça exactement comme vous voyez là
il y a des bars d'attaches pour les
chevaux
peuvent se poser profitez aussi et voilà
là les vététistes ils vont dans un sens
et ils profitent il y a des sens de
circulation tout ça permet de de faire
en sorte finalement de que tout le monde
en profite en respectant l'autre en
respectant la nature parce que le sport
de nature doit se développer mais en
préservant ce qu'on a d'exceptionnel et
là c'est vraiment représentatif ce lieu
là il faut bien diazote que à peu près
260 000 personnes que la montée à la au
loto l'année dernière et depuis le début
de l'année en moyenne quotidienne c'est
1000 voitures donc c'est un lieu très
fréquenté voilà c'est vraiment l'endroit
qui correspond finalement à la culture
réunionnaise de profiter de notre
environnement tout ça et accompagné
évidemment par l'Europe d'accord à 75%
et 25% par département mais c'est
surtout une action concertée tous les
partenaires l'ONF et le gestionnaire il
va agir le parc va veiller à la
préservation tout le monde agit la
commune tout le monde agit pour gérer au
mieux pour que tout le monde en profite
magnifique il vaut le coup d'oeil et ben
voilà notre balade net de bœuf côté
exceptionnel ok la réunion les gaillards
et tout ça rendez vous un prochain
épisode de l'émission car la semaine à
tous
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]